so I've been using my new iPhone 14 pro
Max for the last couple of months and to
be completely honest I thought the brand
new changes and features that Apple
added this time around would be a much
bigger deal in terms of how I use my
phone every day and the overall quality
of life improvements now don't get me
wrong there are some changes that I'm
actually very happy about and I don't
regret upgrading at all even though
there are a couple of drawbacks compared
to the previous model but let's start
with the good stuff first now by far the
biggest change that I've been waiting
for for years now was the always on
display and it's finally here the only
thing that surprised me was that despite
Apple's Best in Class technique for how
it works specifically being able to go
down to one Hertz display refresh rate
when using the always-on display it
still had a noticeable hit to my battery
life because of that I decided to create
a custom Focus this mode that doesn't do
anything but change the wallpaper to an
all black wallpaper with red text and an
effort to save battery life since red
LED light uses the least amount of power
and voltage leading to the most battery
life savings now thankfully over the
past two months Apple has released some
new updates that have definitely helped
with battery life and it's safe to say
that it's now almost as good as it was
with the 13 Pro Max but I find myself
still using this black wallpaper setup
since I'm so used to it and I still
really like it especially for the
contrast on the home page but as far as
quality of life improvements it's really
helped me in two ways the first one is
that I no longer accidentally forget
about notifications that previously
popped up for a few moments before the
screen turned off because now they stay
there on the display so I'm constantly
reminded of them and that helps me with
my issue of forgetting to reply to
Notifications now the second quality of
life Improvement is the fact that I can
Now swipe to wake and unlock the phone
with just a single swipe whereas
previously you'd have to tap first to
wake it up and then swipe to unlock now
I know first world problems but it has
made it so much more convenient to
unlock my phone when I'm at my desk now
moving on from that we've got to talk
about the dynamic Island which at first
seemed so cool and convenient when Apple
showed it off making it seem like it
would always be useful but it just
doesn't seem like it's been that useful
for me but now that I actually think a
little bit more deeply about it it's
been extremely useful in a passive sense
for example the worst thing in the world
used to be the low battery pop-up that
would take up the entire display and
force you to press ok but now it simply
just pops up in the island without
bugging you same thing for the little
face ID notification which pops up
subtly at the top as well as the ringer
vol volume indicator it just gives those
previously annoying things a better more
subtle location and I really like that
on top of that the island has been
extremely useful because it gives you a
convenient way to quickly open up the
app that's using it like for example
going directly into the music app
instead of swiping through the app
switcher to find it and also when you're
on a phone call you can quickly tap on
the island and go back to it if you need
to quickly switch the Bluetooth Source
or anything else and my personal
favorite having the timer always show
the countdown of seconds at the top has
been invaluable but other than that
there hasn't been much use to it and I'm
actually more happy about the removal of
the ugly Notch especially since the new
speaker Grille is Razor thin and hardly
noticeable which I love and surprisingly
the speakers have gotten even louder and
better across the board in terms of
sound quality and I like like to use my
iPhone speakers a lot when watching
YouTube videos so I enjoy that change
now my favorite iPhone feature is still
Mac safe because I love using it with my
macsafe wallet and especially my
wireless charger in the car but our
sponsor base us has this awesome new
Mega attached 20 watt magnetic wireless
charging power bank with 10 000
milliamps of power that holds on very
well and automatically charges your
iPhone at up to 7.5 Watts or 15 watts
for Androids it also has a nice foldable
kickstand built in for watching videos a
nice LED status light indicator and even
20 watt PD full fast charging using a
cable to plug it in directly from the
power bank to your iPhone they've also
got their six in one power combo 40 watt
power strip which can charge up to six
devices is including 20 watt fast
charging two of them at once since it
has two USBC ports a USB a port and
three power outlets right on the Strip
itself for plugging in anything you'd
like so it works like an extension cable
but with surge protection built in and
of course the extra three USB ports
which is awesome so be sure to check out
both the power strip and Max life
battery Bank using the links below now
one of the major downsides of the new
iPhone 14 models that I didn't think
would be a problem is the fact that
Apple got rid of the SIM card slot
forcing people to use e-sim now I myself
had some issues with slow cell service
for the first week of owning this phone
but over the past couple months two of
my family members upgraded to new iPhone
14 Pro Models and both of them had major
issues with connecting their service
because of a lack of the SIM card slot
and because of that they either had to
call in in or walk into their service
provider's office to get it working
which is of course extremely annoying
now as far as the actual performance of
the iPhone 14 pro I literally haven't
noticed any difference in actual speed
or snappiness of this iPhone compared to
the previous one but I'm pleasantly
surprised and satisfied with the big
Improvement in cooling since I've rarely
had the display on the 14 pro Max dim
compared to last year when it would
happen on occasion but now it rarely
ever happens mostly when I'm in direct
sunlight on a very hot summer day now
the new camera changes are where I was a
little bit disappointed but at the same
time extremely satisfied so let me
explain what I mean in some aspects of
the camera there is a negligible
difference compared to the previous
model like using the main camera in
broad daylight but with all of the other
cameras I'm seeing some improvements
especially with the ultra wide camera at
night which used to struggle a lot the
selfie camera also now has a really nice
level of detail and sharpness compared
to before so it's now nice and
competitive against the competition like
the s22 ultra which used to always
destroy the iPhone for selfies but out
of everything I take portrait mode
photos the most and I'm extremely happy
about how well portraits turn out with
improvements to the blur edging and
especially the color reproduction and
glow during the sunset golden hour and I
really appreciate that Apple added the
2x crop mode button that also works with
portraits if you want a specific Zoom
length so it's very convenient and by
the way the 2x crop mode actually works
and greatly improves the quality
compared to previously but a major game
changing feature this year is the new 48
megapixel Pro raw photo feature which
gives you extremely detailed photos
using the main camera and this has
already come in handy to take group
photos of people with insane amounts of
detail now initially I was annoyed by
this feature because Apple forces you to
shoot in the Pro raw format which uses a
massive amount of storage but I
discovered a shortcut that can bulk
convert those files into heic files that
barely take up any storage but retain
most of the detail so I'm gonna add a
link in the description to how to create
that shortcut and finally I'm really
disappointed that Apple didn't give us
8K video recording even though the new
48 megapixel sensor was basically built
for it so I'm sure it's coming next year
but at least the 4K recording still
beats out the competition so I guess it
doesn't matter that much and I'm so glad
that cinematic mode finally supports 4K
resolution so it's 5 finally viable and
looks really good compared to portrait
video on any other phone now one
drawback that Max mentioned in a
previous video is the display glass
quality being easier to scratch and yes
I have noticed that it scratches easier
especially when I dropped it onto gravel
you could probably notice in the b-roll
of this video that it is scratched up
but despite all of that my experience
has been good and I feel like I've
enjoyed more of the passive features of
the new 14 pro Max compared to the
features that Apple actually focused on
in their presentation and despite the
limited number of drawbacks I'm still
very happy with this upgrade and looking
forward to what Apple's gonna come out
with next year so hopefully you enjoy
this two month review and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]